Best known as the young golden haired
woman living alongside humankind's closest
relatives.
This scientist,
turns activist,
has devoted her life to understanding
and working to save chimpanzees from near
extinction.
How Unorthodox methods of observation
revolutionized how scientists conducted
animal reception,
the wild,
deep,
long held assumptions about primates
behavior and showed the world how much we
have in common with the animal kingdom.
Let's learn more about the legendary
British primatologist ecologist,
anthropologist and UN messenger of peace.
Jane Goodall,
Mary Jane Morris.
Scoodle was born in London,
England on April third,
1934.
She was the oldest of two girls,
born to farther mortimer and engineered
race car driver and two mother van,
a successful novelist exactly
four years following Jane's birth,
a younger sister,
judith was born and completed the family.
This API force and note it would
be short lived with World War Two.
You declared in England in 1939.
Jane's father enlisted
and was posted to France.
From then on,
he would become a distant
figure in Jane's life only.
Rarely coming home when he was on leave
after the allies declared victory in the
war was over.
The good old marriage ended in divorce
a few years before Jane must have known
it was coming.
The youngster wrote a
heartfelt letter to her father,
pleading him to wait until
she was 12 years old.
The divorce of Jane's parents,
method of greater impacts on her if her
mother hadn't been such an influential
and supportive parents.
Jane says it was her mother primarily.
This encouraged her to
live out our passions,
saying,
Jane,
if you really want something
and if you work hard,
take advantage of opportunities,
never give up.
You will somehow find a way.
My mother would later play a
role in Jane's early career,
traveling with Jane and
staying on the camp,
but the Gombe Reserve.
Jane spent the majority of her
childhood growing up in her maternal
grandmother's 18,
72 victorian house in the resort town
of Bournemouth on the south coast of
England.
They had a yard with a
garden and trees were.
Jane spent most of her free
time surrounded by women.
Jane shared the residents with her mother,
sister,
grandmother,
and two aunts.
It was a happy home and a place
good old now in her eighties,
goes back to when she needs
to relax and recharge.
She says all my childhood books,
the trees.
I climbed as a trials,
the cliffs where I walked.
I'm blessed in this way.
Young Jane Develops in early
fascination with wild animals.
Just over a year old Jane's father,
gifted tyree lifelike,
three foot tall,
stuffed chimpanzee that she affectionately
named jubilee and carried around with
her everywhere.
Jane's Mother's friends were quite
horrified by the toy chimpanzee fairing.
It would give the young toddler nightmare.
It's quite the opposite,
though.
Jane loved the toy and she still has it.
Over 80 years later being that Jane
devoted her life to researching and saving
chimps,
the only gift of stuffs chimpanzee
seems like the ultimate foreshadowing,
but Jane admits she is keen on all
animals and would have studied and other
species if the circumstances
had been different.
In fact,
as a go,
Jane did not limit herself to learning
about just one kind of animal.
Jane would often be outside the family
home and the yard quietly observing,
sketching or writing notes about
birds and other creatures have.
Family had a host of pets,
including a tortoise and
the dog and the young Jane,
so can many more including racing snails,
caterpillars,
the lizard and the canary.
Jane was an avid reader to some of her
favorite books included Dr doolittle.
Tarzan in the jungle book.
Reading these books ignited a desire to
go to Africa someday to observe and to
write about wild animals.
Jane was also a curious and patient
young step once when Jane was five years
old,
her parents could not find her errands,
presumed to missing.
As panic ensued in search began.
It turns out to Jane had been sitting in
the hen house waiting for the chickens
to lay eggs.
This quiet observation and persistence
is the hallmark of our good old would
later conductor research
at gone best stream.
While Jane entertains fanciful thoughts
of Africa and long to be outside in
nature,
she was still a young.
I'm enrolled at the
uplands private school.
By all accounts.
She was a good students,
but felt the routine of
the classroom unbearable.
At 16,
she confided in her diary writing,
woke up to be faced by yet
another dreary day of torture,
that gloomy place of discipline
and learning where one
is stuffed with education
from days dorn today's Eve,
despite these feelings that she managed
to embrace us school studies and
finished strong focusing her
interests in biology and English.
She even won two prizes for essay
writing in 1953 and at the urging of her
mother Jane and in the London's Queen
Secretarial College and graduated one year
later after receiving a qualification,
Jane held clerical jobs in
Bournemouth and Oxford University.
She also sometimes waited tables and
took a part time job with a film company
still.
Jane never gave up on her dream of going
to Africa even if the idea seemed far
fetched.
In 1955,
Jane Goodall received a letter from
Khloe and old school friends with an
invitation to come to Kenya.
The day had finally come.
It was the opportunity that
she had been waiting for.
She saved hard for the
fair and in March of 1957,
embarks on a three week journey by ship.
Soon after arriving in Kenya,
Jane took a job in the capital city of
Nairobi and demands of the famous British
paleontologist Louis liekly,
who was then the curator of
the Natural History Museum.
The museum,
Jane at this point was just 23 years old,
leaky assertive Charles Darwin's
theory of evolution and believed humans
originated in Africa.
He was motivated to find the missing link
and we're searching for just the right
person to study primates in the
wild rather than in captivity.
Researcher vapes in their natural habitat
has not been carried out before in
this manner and leaky soar in Jane,
the perfect candidate to conduct the
study not only need to Jane exhibit the
enthusiasm he was looking for,
but she also had the
temperament to sustain long
periods of time in the African
Bush with a mind,
uncluttered and unbiased by theory.
Up until this time,
good old has no formal scientific
training or academic credentials that
qualified her to conduct such a study.
Not to mention women scientists who
are practically unheard during the 19
fifties and sixties.
Nevertheless,
Blakey took a chance on the young woman
first hiring her as a secretary and then
sending out to the Gulf stream
reserve in Tanzania in 1960.
Jane was on her phd later in
1965 from Cambridge University.
The degree it would earn Jane respect
to the fields and an hour to receive
funding for research
in 1968 at the age of 26 Jane Google
Inbox for the gun best dream reserve now
part of the Gombe
National Park in Tanzania,
Uganda is bordered by the
longest lake in the world,
Lake Tanganyika in the Goma
region of the country in 1960.
When Jane began her research,
the forests have gumbo the parts of a
continuous chain throughout Burundi,
Rwanda and Uganda and scratched
Westwood's toothy Great Congo Basin.
Jane's destination was only accessible
by boat and as the land was characterized
by steep valleys and
lush green rain forests,
the African Bush and waters were
alive with many species of wildlife,
birds and fish today and remains one
of the best places on earth to observe
primates in their natural habitat.
Goodwill's mission was to learn everything
she possibly could about the wild
chimpanzees.
Arlene gone back.
Her mother accompanies her on the
trip for the first few months.
The local authorities believing a young
British woman would never survive alone
in the wilderness.
Bops labeled right though the dangers
of nature were less of a concern at the
time.
Civil war in the Congo had flooded
with refugees for several weeks.
Jane,
her mother runs one.
Kirk were forbidden to travel to the
stream and waited out the conflict in a
prison camp until it was safe.
Again,
thinking back on her first Dang gone bear.
Jane recalls looking up from
the shore to the forest,
hindering the apes and the
birds and smelling the plants.
I'm thinking it was very,
very unreal.
Jane's early attempts at getting
close to chimpanzees failed.
She could get no closer than 500 yards.
She found another trip and established
a pattern of consistent observation by
appearing in the same spot each morning
along the stream near the chimps feeding
area.
It was one male chimpanzee who
allowed Jane within close range.
She tempted him with your
banana and named him David,
graded for his white tufted chin.
Once does allow Jane to
get close and to watch him.
Other members of the group started to
feel comfortable and accept our presence.
No other human up until now
had ever gotten so close
to chimpanzees in the wild.
It would take two years for the chimps
to show no fear of her and she was
allowed to observe them almost
as if she was a chimp self.
Jane imitated them,
eat their foods and
spend time in the trees.
She would become closely acquainted with
over half of the 100 or so chimps in
the reserve.
Much of the horror of some scientists,
Jane gave all the chimps names like flow,
Fifi,
Flynn's and Mr Greg Hall at this time.
One was careful not to give human
characteristics to animals for fear of
engaging in anthropomorphism.
Researchers tended to use numbers instead,
good old would later recall,
these people were trying to
make ufology a hard science,
so they objected.
Choirs unpleasantly to my naming,
my subject sand for suggesting
that they have personalities,
minds,
and feelings.
Critics aside,
Jane continued to practice.
She believed that empathy was the key
to detecting slight changes in mood or
attitude,
and those changes could provide
insights into complex social processes.
Within weeks had gone bad,
Jane was making new discoveries in
turning conventional thought on its hat,
making tools and using tools was thought
to be an exclusive traits of humans and
not animals.
Yes,
Jane witness David graded using a blade
of grass to extract termites from a
mountain stands on another occasion.
He stripped leaves from a twig to
gain better access to his prey.
This was the first recorded
time in history that another
species how to used or
modifying tools leaky.
It was so excited.
He famously exclaimed,
we must now redefined man redefined
tool or accepts chimpanzees as human.
He was surely exaggerating,
but the discovery was a major blow
to the notion of man the toolmaker.
A few weeks after the
toolmaking revelation,
Jane observed David [inaudible] eating
what looks like a piece of meat.
It was a piglets,
and so the long held theory of primates
as strictly vegetarians swelled.
That was also debunked
through Jane's observations,
the world would also learn chimps,
engaging cannibalism and warfare.
Jane witnessed a brutal four year war
with a neighboring tribe that devastated
the chimps.
MAILCHIMP's also routinely patrol the
borders of their territory and will attack
a solitary male chimpanzee from another
tribe in order to protect their area.
This dark side of chimpanzee behavior,
Jane Goodall likened to gang
activity living amongst the primates.
Jane observed that chimpanzees have
complex brains and social systems.
The caste system of chimpanzee society
places the dominant male at the top,
which is often ranked by how intense
his performances at feedings.
Over the course of her research,
Jane discovered chimps to develop
long term bonds with each other have
ritualized behaviors and even a
primitive language with 20 unique sounds.
Chimpanzees possessed
individual personalities and
communicate through touch and
body language.
They kiss and embrace each other,
give pats on the back,
shake their fists,
and engage in a whole variety
of other nonverbal ways.
Jay noted the males do not play
an active role in the family.
This is simply left up to the females.
Jane observed the strong bond in the
mother child relationship and it's found
that maternal instincts
are taught not inherent.
Chimpanzees learn through observation,
imitation,
and practice the chimpanzees with
good mothers who were above all else
supportive ended up being
good mothers themselves.
The ones who were poor ended up having
female offspring that was also poor,
mothering Jane even theorize that chimps
may have a sense of self and perhaps a
spiritual connection.
How research concluded that mother
centric groupings along with sex,
food sharing and grieving
all the essential components
of chimpanzee society.
Good old publication.
The chimpanzees have gone bad.
Patterns of behavior is the definitive
work on the behavior of chimpanzees.
It would have become the core body
of work used to establish chimps,
gorillas,
and had been as hominids.
The only discoveries of toolmaking and
meat eating chips and the idea of young
woman living in the jungle caught the
interest of national geographic and in
1962 they sent it to the dashing Dutch
photographer Baron Hugo Evon Loueke to
film her work,
fell in love while on assignments,
and as they were in 1960
for three years later,
they had their son,
you go junior,
who she called Grub life,
seemed idyllic for Jane,
doing what she loved most,
being with and writing about
chimpanzees and that were expelled.
This good old lens,
the wild chimpanzees ad in 1965 and
thrust Jane under the spotlight and that
same year Jane received her phd from
Cambridge even though it was his idea and
he pushed Jane to pursue her doctorate.
She acknowledged it was important saying
that Cambridge taught me to think in a
scientific way so I
could stand up to people.
It taught me to think logically.
I loved it and I loved analyzing the data.
It was a very important
part of my development.
Jane and Hugo's marriage
lasted a decade and my 1974,
the pack called it quits.
They remained on good terms.
She had married Derick Bryson member of
Tanzania and parliaments and director of
Tanzania national parks
the following year.
They had five good years together
until his death in 1980 from cancer.
Jane was devastated by the loss,
but she came to terms with us.
I went to Columbia and the
forest is very healing.
You get this endless cycle of living and
dying and things fell into perspective.
In 1971,
Jane Goodall published one of our most
popular and well known books in the
shadow of man.
A vivid description has brought the
chimps to life and bridged the gap between
science and entertainments.
Jane published many more books after
she able to professorship at Stanford
University and was appointed honorary
visiting professor of sociology at the
University of Dar es Salaam in Tanzania.
In 1977,
Dr Goodall founded the
Jane Goodall Institute,
Jay g,
I with a mission to protect
the chimpanzees and further
the research had gone
back.
These soft spoken Jane seems
and unlikely celebrity,
but she would find her
academic respectability and
its popularity and advantage
when speaking on behalf of the chimps
that she so loved over the course of our
research at gone,
bears became increasingly
clear that the wildlife there,
including the chimpanzees,
were at significant risk.
In fact,
by the 19 eighties,
chimpanzees were an endangered species.
Their home and resources were being
destroyed at an alarming rate.
After attending a conference organized
by the Chicago Academy of Sciences in
1986 to coincide with the publication
of the chimpanzees have Gumbo.
Goodwill found herself at a turning
point at 52 years old sounds.
After 25 years of field research,
Jane wins on the road to educate the
public on the vanishing habitats,
the bushmeat trade,
animal trafficking,
and the unethical treatment of animals
used in modern medicine and for
scientific research.
In 1990,
the revelation came that Jane must turn
her attention to humans in order to save
her chimps.
While flying over gone there,
she saw the hill stripped bare.
By deforestation,
the local villagers were responsible
having over farmed their lands.
We've listed options left,
they'd taken the trees and the national
park to sell his timber in order to
survive.
At that moment,
Jane realized that unless you address
poverty and to work to improve the lives
of villages,
you can never expect to conserve
the lands and save the wildlife.
She explained everything
is interconnected.
You learn that in the rainforest.
Soon off to the Jgi launched
programs focused on education,
family planning,
water management,
sustainable agriculture,
and microcredit for women.
Thanks to,
uh,
work with the Jane Goodall Institute's
Lake Tanganyika catchments,
reforestation and education projects.
The Gomberg chimps now have three to
four times more forest than they had 10
years ago.
Oh,
welcome.
The ethical treatment of captive chimps
that the medical community to steer away
from the using cross
species organ transplants,
also known as xenotransplantation.
Further goodall has made strides to phase
out the use of chimpanzees and medical
research.
Council works tirelessly an average of
300 days per year to spread the mission
of the Jgi.
The institute has offices around the
globe with programs primarily in Africa to
involve the local people in community
centered conservation and other
initiative.
The roots and shoots program
is an operation in over
130 countries and works to
foster environmentalism and
peace among the world's children.
Good old passionate fight
to preserve the welds.
Chimpanzee population has included
service on the save the chimps sport,
the world's largest chimpanzee sanctuary,
located in Fort Pierce,
Florida.
Over a long career,
good all became the
world's expert on primates.
Per field work has led to the publication
of numerous articles and five major
books.
She has also written a number of
children's books such as grubbed,
the Bush baby chimpanzees I love
and my life where the chimpanzees,
countless people over
multiple generations.
I've gotten to know her work through
the National Geographic magazine,
television programs,
and imax film,
Jane Goodall's,
wild chimpanzees,
Jane and new documentary film by Brett
Morgen was released in 2017 to critical
acclaim and features over 100 hours of
archived national geographic footage.
The trailblazer,
Jane Goodall,
is still captivating
audiences all this time later.
Good old has received
numerous honors and awards,
including the gold medal of conservation
from the San Diego Zoological Society
in Nineteen Seventy Four.
The J dot Paul Getty Wildlife
Conservation Prize in 1984,
the Schweitzer metal of the Animal Welfare
Institute in Nineteen Eighty seven,
the National Geographic Society
Centennial Award in Nineteen Eighty Eight,
the Kyoto prize in basic sciences in 1990,
the National Geographic Society,
Hubbard Medal for distinction
and then exploration,
discovery and research
in 1995 and in 2002,
she was named messenger of peace
by the United Nations in 2003,
she became a dame of the British empire.
And in 2006,
She was honored with the 60th anniversary
metal of the UNESCO and French Legion
of honor.
She also holds multiple honorary
doctorates from various prestigious
universities around the world.
Jane's research continues at the Bombay
Stream research center established by
good old in 1965.
It is the longest running study of
chimpanzees the world has ever seen.
The center hosts visiting researchers and
continues to further our understanding
of chimpanzee health group dynamics,
diet,
and more.
The information gathered here can
also inform conservation efforts.
These days dream visitor
center at least twice a year,
but all the trips screen
you have now passed on.
Jane's legacy is more than that.
Contributions to science or her activism,
how to termination and body of work
inspires us to believe in ourselves and
remember our connection to
nature and what we leave behind.
She wants us to think about the
future and our role in protecting us.
Saying,
I care passionately about nature.
I care passionately about children.
I have three grandchildren.
I think about their children.
If we can't do things differently,
what is the world going
to be like in 50 years?
Above all else,
Jane has taught us that it
is up to us to make a change.
Every individual matters.
Every individual has a role to play.
Every individual makes a difference.
Only if we understand what we care.
Only if we can.
Where we help?
Only if we help shall we will be saved.
The least I can do is speak out for those
who cannot speak out for themselves.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.